[Música]
y taiana y ser parte de este primer test
es para mí muy emoción
bueno pensarán que estoy loca o que
quizás soy muy arriesgada al presentarme
en este me verte con un sombrero de
papel en la cabeza
pero no es ni lo uno ni lo otro
en realidad quería llamar su atención y
debo felicitarlo por su capacidad de
observación
pero me pregunto si siempre es así o con
el día a día vamos perdiendo esa
capacidad
unos mil nos quedamos en aspectos
meramente superficial que hace que
juzguemos a partir de lo que miramos más
no de lo que observa
a partir de una experiencia personal
hace unos meses
fui a ver una obra que parecía
interesante dentro de las propuestas que
se presentaban en la tienda no
solo con un detalle
era en un cementerio que queda al sur
no me imaginaba qué tipo de obra podría
presentarse en un lugar tan peculiar
pero recordé también que hacía muchos
años había ido a ver al presbítero
maestro don juan tenorio
habían sillas entre los cuarteles y cada
vez que terminaba un acto nos íbamos de
un lugar a otro
era la noche solamente estaban los
artistas y los espectadores lo cual le
daba un ambiente un poco tenebroso
entonces recordé eso y dije bueno esta
obra a ver algo similar sólo que era a
las 11 de la mañana con lo cual no
parecía ser tan musculoso ni como gross
bueno fui
lo primero que vi no habían signos
entonces dije la oración
con las demás personas que estábamos
allí nos mirábamos desconcertado sin
saber qué hacer de pronto vino una de
las organizadoras y nos entregó a cada
uno de nosotros un auditor
no había escenario
no habían sido y no había martes
lo único que había eran los espectadores
una guía
y tiempo
y la salud
bueno lo primero que el aún más ordenó
porque nos paráramos frente a una nave
y trataremos de imaginarnos y unirá a la
persona que dicen temprado
si tratáramos de reconstituir
mentalmente como había sido su vida de
que podría parecer
fuerte no
bueno en ese momento supe que algo iba a
pasar
luego la voz nos ordenó no saliéramos
del cementerio de la india todos nuevos
atrás de nosotros siguiendo una ruta por
las distintas calles de acción
en ese momento empecé a conectarme
conmigo misma con el silencio uno un
tornado en mi cabeza era la voz
no había conexión entonces estábamos
allí nuestra vida
comencé a observar un árbol frondoso
patrones de colores
una casa con una fachada
en vez de nos miraba y no saludaba
d-link y gran pregunta
se observa
y otras cosas no están sirviendo
este tránsito
perdiendo mis cosas maravillosas o
terribles y no me doy cuenta buenas pero
no las registro
vivo vivimos de espaldas a un conjunto
de esposas que pasan a nuestro alrededor
y yo recuerdo
hace muchos años cuando era mucho mejor
que enseñaba una academia de una italia
un curso de cera
el rendimiento que estaba asignado con
los accidentes geográficos la curvatura
de los vídeos las montañas las cosas
internas y externas del actual
un día cuando me tocaba entre de
mezclarse incluso con una colina que me
dice hay un chico de polo rojo pensó
en ese momento múltiple para mí
y ahora le doy la razón al bloque
anterior cuando nos decía que todos
deberíamos haber estado
yo soy profesor diciendo que debía ser
un deber también marcar
pero
y como ayudan experto observadora de las
montañas de los ríos y demás no sota
lovic inmediatamente en mente que estaba
sentado en las primeras dudas entonces
decidí darle una clase particular me
acerqué a él
y trate de hablar lo más modular mi voz
más con los labios para que pudiera leer
me incluyo entender las capas de las más
a propósito era estrato dos turnos
los chicos no me quitaba la mirada
pondrá con central por momentos apareció
que estaba un poco nervioso pero éste
envía la situación
cuando termine la clase
espectacular solo por un metal
cuando me estaba retirando siento una
voz que de álava determinó un poco raro
y cuando golpeó
miraba a un chico de palabra
genera un tipo de color rojo innova en
que el año ha estado entrando
prácticamente la clase
y esta anécdota la podemos trasladar a
cualquier aspecto de nuestros vinos
nosotros no tenemos esa capacidad de
dulce de observar para aprender para
aprender
y justamente en ese aprendizaje
hay cosas que vemos de manera diferente
no todos miramos walt no todos
observamos igual porque vemos cosas
diferente porque va a depender mucho de
nuestra propia experiencia
los invito a ver
esa imagen
una
unos perfiles una papa
alguien me otra cosa
un candelabro
aunque un abismo open bueno yo no me voy
a confesar que la primera vez que vi
esta imagen no vi nada lo que ustedes lo
que vi fue un señor con un gran sombrero
en la cabeza
y porque por fin esto y porque demás
cosas diferentes
porque registramos de acuerdo a nuestro
experiencia y porque envió un señor con
una con un sombrero raro en la cabeza
probablemente porque cuando yo era una
chica mi abuelo estaba sombrero es muy
probable que yo siempre recuerdo y haya
asociado a esta figura al muerto
y entonces
sabemos que observamos de acuerdo a lo
que tenemos
pero no soy reservado a veces nos
quedamos a mirar si pones una diferencia
entre observar y mirar y cuando yo
observo me comprometo con esto mis
emociones van con olor cuando me no no
me van a decir alguno de ustedes que
dice voy a observar un celular no
decimos voy a mirar de celular porque
nos estamos comprometiendo con el
celular
no es lo mismo
a comprometerse cada vez más con la
observación pero así
como nosotros observamos también no se
observan ustedes están observando en
nuestro momento a mí y probablemente a
las personas que están a su costado y se
están haciendo una imagen de esa persona
a mí me pasó una cosa muy extraña
también hace mucho tiempo yo estaba en
la cola del banco
ya mí simplemente no me daba mucho que
me acordara me ponía un poco nervioso y
esa vez estaba yo haciendo la cola en el
banco y sentía un señor tiene una linda
yo entré que me sentía insegura y un
poco inclinada no sabía lo que ocurría
lo único que quería era terminar más
grande en salir lo más pronto del cuando
ya estaba por salir el señor no pudo más
y se acercó hacia donde yo estaba y me
dijo
tu grupo
su lonchera está abierta todo lo que
tiene es eterna se ha derramado
excesivamente cuando el pie me salí
bastante rápido obviamente y claro una
hora
confía en las personas nos hemos vuelto
tan indolentes que cuando alguien
simplemente más pudo ayudar nos parece
que en realidad que está buscando otra
pero ya no sabemos diferenciar un
espiroidal y túnez
yo no quisiera comprometer así los
cerradores
observa para conectarnos con el otro
para hacer un pacto para ponernos en los
zapatos de las otras personas
ya lo decía un gran
alejandro dumas
en el estado
pero sabes mucho más
colapsa
vamos
[Aplausos]